Vladimir yejoff was killed defending the
Eastern Ukrainian town of bakmut in
December he joined the army after Russia
invaded Ukraine telling his family he
wanted to fight for its freedom
his brother Slava says Vladimir was
proud of Ukraine and took part in
pro-western protests in 2014 so he
wasn't surprised when Vladimir enlisted
and says he kept in touch with his
family by messenger from the front lines
every morning
before going to the mission he said we
are going to the mission and every
evening when they got back
he messaged us that there that he saved
their back
Slava remembers how he heard about
Vladimir's death
my father made a call to me
I I couldn't believe it I I didn't want
to believe it
but uh
well
it was hard hard time for us all
for us all
the brothers grew up in Northern Ukraine
and were close
went on to become an online game tester
and developer in Kiev he helped create a
popular game called stalker the face of
one of the characters is modeled on his
but the virtual world of Shooters is a
far cry from the reality of War
the battle between Ukrainian and Russian
forces for bakmut is brutal fighting's
intense it's been described as a living
hell Slava says he could see how
harrowing it was in his brother's face
in his final weeks but he says for
Vladimir died doing what he believed in
I'm sure that he would done it again
has behind his family and two young
children like many ukrainians he paid
the ultimate price defending the country
he loved Natasha Butler Al Jazeera Kiev
Ukraine